and here's Simmons coming up with a
turnover the great look at that I didn't
think I'd get that excited in the
preseason game finds a streaky Markel
along the baseline that's just smart
basketball short Donovan has to hurry
he's at half-court lets it fly horn
sound Oh half-court bucket yeah they'll
review it but that's going home for
three maybe that kick starts you talk of
the quarter of the game and looked to me
that he got
Simmons just takes a little play by
Simmons man Marcus Morris number three
look at that pass nice finish how about
the finish there's the cut my fault
what's you guys playing together not a
lot of court time between these two last
year they're getting the shots they want
they're just not knock them down a
little bit better than early on in the
first quarter while moment but baseline
Jovie Donovan Mitchell we talked about
his athleticism right here we've seen
plenty of those it just keeps going up
and up it makes my knees very polar back
there listen again that's what you want
to be doing it down the stretch when the
game's on the line you're in the behind
nicely done here shots and dropping a
dime on Ben's Senate and they're
competing - they're competing at both
ends
[Applause]
yes the end here comes our play in the
day tomorrow unbelievable
this shot look at the explosiveness with
the left hand to right and extends
struggled in the first half it's young
for three and Simmons has it for the
Sixers nice spot of covington who throws
it down the fifth assist of the game for
simmons about how roberts defense sets
up his offense that time a good
challenge on trey you have against the
Jazz in Dallas ain't going to go took it
away from dungeons gets it back puts up
the shot wash down we get a missed layup
here he just kind of hangs and then
grabs it turns the ball over he's in the
air one one thousand two and thousands
will use the backboard for any kind of
support Davis gave it away
[Music]
beat Ben Simmons you see right there off
of the steel hammock it's a tool nobody
offered up any resistance on the
Seminole run over the last minute to
change angles - OH Oh put that one down
young fella well Ricky Rubio doing a
nice job running this play joke gets it
up to Donovan watch this boom the man
can sky sky Walker and we love to see
that when he can score and he can score
punches we talked about again that
Cavalier game last year when he was in
Cleveland Wow Ben Simmons finished the
job compliments are firk on court bought
Wendy's seems likes that and the
defender coming over to interject which
took he got a piece of it Ben's still
able to catch it yeah there's the foul
right here's another guy looking to make
plays Mitchell splitting the defenders
and it goes in how did it happen
Donovan Mitchell we're out there
shooting just 5 of 16 from the field Sam
it's all beautiful look from Simmons and
the butler the Simmons you've got to
find a way to slow the freight train
down because if he gets by and then at
opens up your options and a really good
job by Butler to get behind the defense
danny green lungs Turner who's got a
really nice job off the bench
very good pass in tight quarters in
corporal with the steel
[Applause]
get it in the area code Donovan's gonna
find it that's incredible
he caught them rondae hollis-jefferson
shaken up earlier is back the Sixers
come up with a turnover
[Applause]
you know it's like we're gonna be smart
well like who does anybody try to be
dumb bill McGee is seven to the rim will
feel that one tomorrow
well those tough passes yeah I'm sure
you've run the floor and had some really
weird passes computer
no pants they're simply a slant for
Simmons he is playing with a lot more
emotion after showing some unusual
emotion and picking up a tactic
yeah and you can see how he plays
[Applause]
for the last couple of nights ago in
Portland is they run at the Swim at
Simmons
second straight falling 221 and 16 as
simmons some wizardry there as he
knocked it off
Mitchell Wow a better lettuce isn't
right here baby you so long to season
like 15 his career-high
[Applause]
JoEllen pitas first assistant nice
little ball movement that's a nice look
right there - cutting pen Simmons in
traffic for Nick defenders around them
and Joe goes out with the foul there
[Applause]
how to start
22 points on a quick seven here in the
third
now the other one watch this move little
between the legs and sham and goes
somewhere else
mitchell pulls up straight between them
Robert becoming the elite player that
he's become defensively the to explain
what just happened there at Benson huge
pass man
is denied by OKC tonight
[Applause]
mr. Mitchell oh boy
pull up impressive Mitchell jazz 7 get
the feeling that this Philadelphia team
who's gonna look a lot different in
April than the GM oh absolutely and beat
had the chance to line up the seams
Simmons cleaned it up more look at
Simmons here Donovan saves it at
midcourt 15 on the shot clock
shooter was big in the third down of a
time goes up splits right between the
well it goes afonso McKenna his time
green lurking to help behind the pack
[Music]
Green steps under him trying to land
that's a heck of a pass by Simmons a
jump hook right here and I see what
Fremont Green is talking about nine
straight misses from the three losses
but
drives baseline
[Applause]
under their feet by Mitchell this is the
dunk channel bringing you mr. Mitchell
with the legs spread out I mean this is
like nerf hoops type of stuff bowler
down in the basement your kid you put it
on a five-foot hoop and you go up and
you see what you can do
Mitchell's doing it on a 10 foot Oh
unreal Springs Dooley Willie
cauley-stein the 7 footer from Kentucky
frustrated Ole Miss Wright who is right
good news first double pumps drives
inside wants to get closer to the rim
the balls loose Jonathan's got time
[Applause]
watch this whoops
between the legs gotcha just not gonna
get any better
and if it goes
it's got to be applications in this
about Royce Niang are demeaned by
Plumlee he would not be at the top of
the list of offensive Hopkins but that
was well done Simmons and look to Malone
many punches are on the bucket look at
this a little mistake on the exchange of
citizens just like EE Beasley thinks
he's just catching and that puts Plumlee
at a deficit then seven says you just
paid a big-time mistake
[Music]
got free agency versus hornish team
doesn't make the playoffs here's
Jonathan to the drive inside
beer that's right start your free trial
on ESPN plus by downloading the ESPN app
were visiting espn.com and I find that
highlight on ESPN Plus it some Moines
Simmons with a crush
[Applause]
that's the way to go up a terrible pass
and a wonderful with the banks open for
Chris Middleton
he's the second leading scorer shade
under 18 while Simmons on the attack
again he's got five here and the first
11 and a half minutes Donovan fresh off
the bench he knew it peel off in the
shot he just put a rainbow down for
three as he gets a lot of looks like
that the things we talked about what to
watch they're there for a reason I
thought he was fouled but white to pass
as well from it be well sporting the new
headband baseline shut down and it goes
to Donovan 3 to shoot down to the two
have to shoot it that is a deep three
[Applause]
for a reason it wasn't because of his
jump shot is because he knows how to
impact the game there's an example of
impact here expressing himself coming
right down the paint defense by Fournier
Donovan Mitchell the Quin Snyder said
there's really no guarantee as they beat
the shot clock
oh boy the block shot off the time that
makes you just miss the shot when you
get it off
Simmons with six to shoot nasty finished
30 Simmons in lowest scoring corner of
the season for the Ness
Ben Simmons right down the page
expressing himself on TNT double pump so
I honest he gave it away gets his back
four to shoot
down to three I'll have to take that
three deep got it he's on he is just on
sir Institute and that this three puts
him over the twenty point mark for the
21st time this season and be
[Applause]
pushing Kawhi Leonard up he's just
positioning so here's Donovan Mitchell
who has 26 points gets it away and banks
it in what a shot by Mitchell very
creative here getting this one to go a
little push shot first half foot lakes
rivers final seconds no fouls to give
here for Detroit JJ Redick by flash by
driven ball knocked loose thrown up
shotgun go from down by sevens Willis
second remaining
Mitchell Mitchell knocks down a big time
free Donovan Mitchell the top scoring
second-year player in the NBA rainbow is
running from deep for the chance like
Scala in for him
[Music]
Simmons got a dime boy with each and
every game looking more confident with
that jump shot nine to shoot
jhaza put up a left hook himself and
then races down the rebound it didn't
touch ramps with a shot the shot clocks
at three down to two a deep free
Pergamon shot
nice job right here Rudy's stand with
the play getting this steel right here
[Music]
kicking it over in extra passes nice
boys by government help the bridge is
coming late Simmons got it done Ben
Simmons fading away drilled it after JJ
Redick was unable to uncork the three
previous trip down the floor JJ with the
kick into the post Bend with the post up
when they fade away left-hand jumpy and
five rebounds in 25 minutes that's the
beauty of this to you boys
[Music]
one thought he had contact me time
Harris trying to take advantage of his
height advantage on Bazemore Simmons for
the hot potato here one to shoot got it
off and in turns it over go bear trying
to hit Engels threw it right to hearten
but then Rubio picks parties pocket ally
[Applause]
Whiteside negating that one forcefully
Ben Simmons a terrific play on an
inbounds play certainly had his head in
the game knew with the shot clock said
and he tips it in he's got ten here time
transition Mitchell for three
[Applause]
one of the things you toss talked about
is them feeling us this was about pride
there is the contact you feel like
Donovan boy if he makes that it could be
game over sentence one second Simmons
off the glass that in plus the foul Ben
Simmons goes to the free-throw line to
get a chance at a three-point play here
a little hesitation got siak what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content